[Music]
good evening I'm Alexander Rose the
director here at long now we don't have
a long short tonight but I thought I
would take this opportunity to go over a
little bit about where we've come from
it turns out that that this fall will be
our tenth year of doing these seminars
and actually could could we get the
house lights up just a little bit house
lights a little bit cuz I actually want
to see this how many of you were at the
very first Brian you know seminar 10
years ago well about maybe about 50 nice
not bad so as Paul Sappho who's here
tonight knows on our board has said this
is his favorite conference in that it's
just been going for 10 years basically
it's just a very long drawn-out single
conference so this fall we'll be hitting
somewhere around 120 talks and about
7500 people come to them annually like
tonight but one thing that I think a lot
of the people who come to these don't
understand or don't see is the other
half of our audience in fact the other
99% of our audience we get about 500,000
downloads or views of this through our
podcast and the video every year so it's
by far our largest outreach program with
long now the the way that we pay for
this has largely been through all of you
members so how many members are here
tonight so as you know you don't
purchase tickets to come in every night
but you do pay a monthly membership and
that's what that's what keeps this
program going we also have a series of
individual sponsors most of which are
here tonight as well who also pay for
that and that basically makes between
those two things that's over half of
long-nosed operation
budget so thank you to all of you our
sponsors and our members for making that
happen I really appreciate it
[Applause]
so that the real question is what do we
you know where do we go from here ten
years and five hundred thousand people
at least listening and watching annually
and one of the main questions we often
get is you know why don't you do X
speaker who you know fill in the blank
and these talks cost us somewhere
between twelve and twenty thousand
dollars to put on even with amazingly
generous speakers who don't charge us to
do the their normal speaking fee or any
speaking fee to come so we can't just do
every speaker but what we are now
embarking on doing is making our salon
project which will allow us to do
smaller events and much more impromptu
events but we will still be able to
webcast them and and all of that we are
a little bit past halfway in our
fundraising for that and we have just
started demolition this week and we've
started and we'll be starting
construction in the next couple weeks
and so thank you all for getting us to
halfway and if any of you are interested
in helping to get us to the second half
way we are we would be very appreciative
of that as well
and the last thing I wanted to say is
that this whole thing is done with an
amazingly small staff
I think there's at any given day there's
only about four or five of us in the
office and these events are expertly
engineered and put together by daniele
Engleman and her crew and I really want
to thank them for doing that thank you
very much good
good evening I'm Stuart brand from the
long now foundation the idea of the
salon
conversation plus fluids coffee tea
alcohol all of them exotic and full of
time in various respects there's a
Bristlecone gin that we're going to be
serving among other things our speaker
sold this book to me three times because
I'm listening to it in the car and then
I go get the printed Edition and Mark
the parts I really like and then the
Kindle version I take on the plane and I
come back from that and I mark the parts
in the printed version that I really
like and I have to do that because
practically every problem I'm working on
in various respects including bringing
back extinct species has solutions
buried in what our speaker has gotten
into in his lifetime of psychological
research and we say the long now
foundation that one way we state the
goal is to make long-term thinking
automatic and common instead of
difficult and rare well I think we can
add to that we would like to make slow
thinking but our speaker calls system to
thinking automatic and common instead of
difficult and rare here to talk about it
is Daniel Kahneman
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well it's a pleasure to be here it's a
bit of a surprise actually in some way I
you know that my book Thinking Fast and
Slow came out more than a year and a
half now and I'm sick and tired of
talking about it and but when stood
brand asks you to come in and do
anything I suppose I mean he hasn't
asked me to do many things but it's I
think it must be very difficult to
refuse anything that Stuart wants you to
do and also I was particularly
interested because of the tremendous
contrast between our temperaments the
long now foundation as I perceive it is
really you know it's it could stand as a
symbol for optimism not you know long
range optimism I mean thinking big and
thinking long and thinking for and and I
am really a pessimist train
fundamentally a pessimist I don't you
know I think you know I don't want to
think about the future because I don't
think it's going to be too good
I attend I take some pleasure in the
fact that I'm very rarely disappointed
by anything I mean which is you know one
of one of the major advantages I think
of being a pessimist but and this was
what brought me here I mean I'm I'm
going to tell you how I think and so I'm
going to expose you to a semester
thinking for which I suppose must be in
real supply here but but I really longed
to be convinced I would like to be
convinced okay so let me tell you about
fast and slow thinking
you know that there are two fundamental
ways of thinking or two fundamental ways
in which thoughts come to our minds is
completely obvious so it's so obvious
actually that not everybody sees it
immediately and psychologists haven't
done it you know haven't put a lot of
work into that basic idea but the
distinction is very clear you know so if
you say 2+2 something happens to you and
and if you say 17 times 24 I always use
the same two examples probably not much
happens to you as so certainly you don't
408 doesn't come to mind if you unless
you have misspent your youth or
something what would so there is that
difference if you want to get to 408 if
you want to know the answer to 17 times
24 you've got to recognize versus a
multiplication problem you have to bring
up the program that you learned in
school you've got to apply it this is
this is work it is mental work and and
it's very easy to notice that it's
mental work because there are
physiological changes that are
associated with it it's completely
different as as a mental event from what
happens when you know I mentioned 2+2
and the number 4 sort of pops into your
mind you didn't try to bring it to mind
you didn't want to bring it to mind
particularly it just happened so the
difference between fast thinking and
slow thinking is that first thing is
something that happens to you primarily
and slow thinking something that you do
this is it has elements of intention it
has elements of attention it has
elements of control and that's the key
distinction now we when we apply slow
thinking when counter limitations and
then that's a very important
between fast and slow thinking effortful
thinking is something is our ability to
apply effort as quite limited and as we
really cannot do too many things at once
if they demand effort we are likely to
fail if we try to do too many things at
once so you can compute 17 times 24 you
cannot do it while making a left turn
into traffic and you shouldn't try so
that's the and you shouldn't try because
you'll fail and in one of the other the
two tasks and and one of them is much
worse than the other normally by the way
we do have a mechanism that prioritizes
so that mostly when we have competition
between two tasks and we have to choose
some you know we something has to choose
some and we actually have a pretty good
idea of where that thing that chooses is
is in the brain a choice has to be made
and we're very good at that usually not
always but usually we're very good at
that now we need effortful thinking to
do many things we probably need it
whenever we want to hold two ideas at
once and and compare them we can as
you'll see we can easily handle a single
idea or a single very complex idea
single interpretation but holding two
possibilities at once like you do when
you do a deliberate choice that seems to
require effort self-control which is not
slow thinking but the characteristic of
self-control is that it two demands
effort so that if you are very busy or
very tired your self-control is to some
extent depleted and we know that from
many experiments but you know to give
you an example the way that
psychologists sort of preempt the work
of system two or makes
make the way that we make people as we
say cognitively busy is we give them a
set of digits to keep in their mind in
their head and and later we'll test them
and while they are trying to not to
forget those seven digits which require
some rehearsal and some mental work we
give them other tasks and it turns out
that when you are holding seven digits
in your head in very obvious ways your
self-control is impaired so for example
people use more sexist language and when
their self-control is impaired they are
they the choices between desserts is
somewhat of influence they are more
likely to pick the rich and luscious
chocolate cake and less likely to go for
the more virtuous food salad that's
because normally we control ourselves
and when our ability to control
ourselves is is impaired we do what
comes more naturally we yield to
temptation we normally think of
ourselves as system - we're identified
with what we think consciously we are
identified with the things that we
choose consciously the when you generate
a thought like computing 17 times 24 you
are the author of that thought this I
mean we feel some pride in things that
just occurred to us and happened to us
but the authorship of a thought the idea
that it was produced by deliberately
that is a marker system - and we I think
many of us have a sense which I believe
is erroneous that when we have a thought
that just came naturally there is
reasoning behind it that as we could
produce the reasons that led to this
thought this is I think an illusion that
many of us have in many cases as I'll
try to show you there is no reasoning
behind the thought
there is another process there is a
process that they'll call an associative
process in memory so let me give you
another example of system 2 and how it
works and how it fails and that's a
puzzle anybody who's read the book knows
that puzzle it's the best single example
of its kind and and the puzzle is very
straightforward it's a bat and a ball
costs $2 10 the bat costs a dollar more
than the ball how much does a ball cost
and the beauty of that example is that
an association comes to mind really I
think everybody has a dissociation and
that's 10 cents the number ten cents
pops up now that number is wrong and and
it's very easy to find out that it's
wrong to them convince yourself that
it's wrong because you know if it's 10
cents for the ball then it's a dollar
and ten cents for the bat and then it's
a dollar 20 it's totals or something is
wrong the answer is five cents what's
interesting about this problem is that
50 percent of students at Harvard fail
it and they fail it when it's given in a
written questionnaire so what happens to
those 50 percent of people who fail that
test what happens is something really
quite interesting they had that
association ten cents and they didn't
check that as we know about everyone who
makes a mistake on that problem they did
not check themselves an idea came to
mind and they endorsed it and that idea
of endorsing thoughts that come to mind
spontaneously this is what system two
does in many situations I would argue in
most situations it endorses ideas that
came from the associative system which
is a system over which we have no
control so this is a case you know that
particular puzzle it there's a really
broad hint that you should check because
the problem is so obvious
that if you give the obvious answer you
know it's very lazy actually to give the
obvious answer and that's a
characterization I apply to system two
it tends to be lazy it tends to operate
by law of least effort there are
individual differences some people are
much lazier than other people in in the
way they think but but all of us the law
of least effort is really a fundamental
psychological principle that is when
when there are alternative ways of doing
something over time we tend to gravitate
for the way that minimizes F there is a
calculation that is the value of actions
there is a calculation that's performed
in the brain and effort is a cost in
that calculation and so we tend to
minimize effort as I said some people
are more minimized effort but more than
others so that's the way that I'm going
to describe how we think a lot of the
time the basic mechanism in that
suggested answer pops up from the
associative system from fast-thinking
from what I call system 1 thinking and
in most cases the suggestion is endorsed
and we believe what we see we believe
what we think so that's now that
suggests that system 1 is the very large
extent in charge because system 1
generates those possibilities those
suggestions that in general system 2
will adopt and accept now system 2 has
control to some extent that as we could
trick people at least in that problem
people have the opportunity to trick
themselves and they have the opportunity
to decide not to accept that suggestion
but actually to do something else but
much of the time it is system 1
that actually runs the show so that's
the description I'm trying to give you I
say conclude very general way of how the
mind works we have an associative system
that generates automatically I mean you
know without intention without volition
generates ideas generates perceptions
generates an interpretation of the world
quite broadly and then we have sitting
if you will on top of that we have a
system that monitors the quality of you
know our behavior we self monitor we
self control but that system is
relatively it's very costly to apply and
much of the time the monitoring is very
light much of the time though monitoring
is also unnecessary and that is because
that associative system is an absolutely
magnificent piece of work
so most of the time what we do naturally
what we might say you do it what we
think intuitively all of that tends to
be right most of what we do is just fine
and intervention by system to would just
slow things up and make them worse and
you know all athletes know that very
well
that when they when they start thinking
about what they're doing it disrupts the
quality of of what they do because their
skill is disrupted by the operational
system too so I'll talk mostly about
system one and its characteristics and
I'm not going to describe it in full but
I want to give you a sense for how it
works so the automatic operations of
system 1 are involved for example when
well you know if I mention the capital
of Russia
that's like to pursue that something is
retrieved automatically from memory when
you recognize a friend the name might
pop up but actually as you can see
reckon
recognising friend is much more than
retrieving a name you're retrieving
a whole lot of things are happening to
you it's a whole network of ideas
associations emotions all of which are
connected with that friend and all of
which are activated if your friend looks
sad or tired there will be something
that's equivalent to search although
it's search is a little too deliberate -
but what will happen is in memory if
there is a memory a causal explanation
if your friend looks sad and good and
tired and and you there is something
that you know that could explain it that
will come to mind automatically if you
had heard that that his wife is ill that
will come to mind as an explanation of
why you are struck by the fact that he
looks sad or tired when I say your
mother a lot happens including an
emotional response and something also
happened to your face probably that is
associated with that emotion that came
to your mind and it would be sad or
happy angry or loving but what happens
is not a single thought it's a lot is
happening including you know emotional
manifestation facial manifestations and
so on now some of the responses of
system one are probably universal and
unique so obvious example is we don't
learn I mean we are wired to learn to
see things and seeing as I just
interpreting the visual world is the
prime example for me of an operation of
system 1 it is automatic it is fast it
is in general extremely accurate and
those are characteristics of the way
that system
works now there are other things that
are clearly innate or at least universal
to give you an example of an association
you know so consider the two words you
know one classic psychological example
one is maluma and the other is Steketee
and if I asked you to which word go with
which gesture you know this gesture or
this restroom it's completely obvious
what goes with what
so that seems to be universal it seems
to me cross culturally universal
according to some people have done
research on that that's built in fear of
spiders is probably built in and I want
to tell you personal experience which I
think that's a very unusual experience
and that happened to me of something
that is built in an inn system one and
it's a bit of an embarrassing story but
a few years ago
we have a house on grizzly peak in
Berkeley which is very nice Road on top
of the hill and and I was thinking a
walk late in the evening and really
quite late it was deserted and dark and
a car came on the opposite direction and
and they were rowdy youth were in that
car they you know they they really
sounded they sounded as if they'd had
too much beer I mean they they really
didn't sound very nice and I I had that
I have that impression as they were
whizzing past in the other in the
opposite direction and then they stopped
and that there was no obvious reason for
them to stop and then a few of them got
out of the car I could hear that and
they started walking quite fast in warn
me and it was unclear you know what when
they wanted but it really didn't sound
friendly and and they were coming a bit
closer and then something happened to me
which took me it took them by surprise
it took me by surprise I i reenact
and I don't know what I did with my
hands but I roared at the top of my
voice I mean like where that came from
no idea absolutely no idea but it came
from way down deep we have you know
there is an evolutionary history there
are things like fear of spiders and and
you know how how threatened animal we
reacts to a threat and you know possibly
how an old monkey reacts to threatening
juveniles that is built into system one
but of course most of what is in system
1 in associative memory is learned and
what we have is detailed knowledge of
the world that we can access and you
know what in terms of you know for a
computer SFO in the computer age it may
not be all that that fast but it's
pretty extraordinary and you know I have
an example that I mentioned in the book
it's the best and it's very hard when
you've given lots of book talks to think
of better examples so the example I have
in the book is of people listening to
sentences and acts and while their brain
events are recorded and a sentence
spoken in an upper class British male
voice which I will not attempt to to
simulate here it says I have launched
the tools all down my back
and within about the third of a second
there is a characteristic response in
the brain which indicates surprise and
if you stop to think about it this is
astonishing that is what's involved you
know and that is all system one it's
completely automatic it is not there is
no intention that's the way memory works
you had to somehow detect and recognize
this is an upper class you know British
male voice activate a stereotype of what
upper class British
like relate that to the question of
whether they have lodged the twos down
their back that doesn't fit the
stereotype and there's a surprise and
interestingly enough the reaction to
that surprise is system two is activated
and is when there is surprise
we are mobilised to perform antal effort
to perform mental work to make sense of
things normally when things go routinely
and are not surprising system one sort
of system 1 thinking flows when there is
a surprise we can catch the mobilisation
of effort skills are automatic so
driving is an automatic skill chess
playing at a high level is an automatic
skill that is you know tres players
master tres players every single move
that occurs to them is a strong move and
as they they select among strong move
and they knew that consciously and they
you know they can compute for for a
while but the basic selection of moves
is is performed completely automatically
so what happens is when we acquire
skills an activity that at first you
know this is the way we all learn to
drive an activity that at first requires
deliberate thinking and effort where
where is the accelerator where is the
brake all that eventually becomes
completely automatic and and we know how
that happens we know our skills are
required we know that it takes a lot of
practice and we know that immediate
feedback is important and and ultimately
all of that is goes into system one so
we have a rich representation of the
world a representation of skills and an
ancestral memory of you know the time
that I mentioned earlier now there are
interesting mixtures I think there is
evidence
that recognizing that somebody's afraid
maybe innate but recognizing somebody is
styled and doesn't look well I would
expect as a learned skill I mean I
remember being very puzzled as a child
you know how did my mother know that you
know somebody looks tired
but eventually I worked it out and there
are cues we're not not aware of accuse
but the categorization of people is
looking well looking sick looking time
that happens automatically it's a
learned skill now how does this whole
thing works I've mentioned the word
associative memory and it covers a lot
of ground because it covers that what
happens when there is a stimulus how
does a response including a mental
response get generated all that is in
associative memory we have a primitive
notion of what associations are like you
know night day or bread butter but
that's not the interesting associations
they are much much richer than that if
if I mention the relationship between
China and Japan now something happens to
you when I mentioned that and it wasn't
a single idea it wasn't a single word it
was probably you could feel it the whole
network of ideas a whole concept very
rich actually network of ideas was
activated now how do we know that it's
activated we know because the activation
of you know what happened to you when I
mentioned the relationship between China
and Japan we know that you're now
prepared for many other events that
could happen and there is a very simple
test of that and the test is to present
whispered words and to see they've
presented at a very so that they're
barely audible and see which words are
recognized in which are not
and after when I've mentioned the
relationship between China and Japan you
will be quicker to recognize the word
island and there were Navy and possibly
the world war and you are prepared for a
lot of things that belong in the network
of ideas that were activated by that
concept now you don't have the whole
history but but you can feel that this
activation was quite dreadful and quite
rich now here I'm coming to something
that's really quite important which is
that how we interpret events and stimuli
as they occur is again tends to be
determined by the context by how it fits
with other things that are going on in
our mind at the time so stand an example
not mine it's standard psychological
example is an approach the bank when I
mentioned that sentence the word that
sentence is really ambiguous you
probably thought of the bank as a
financial institution but if it was in
the context of fishing the bay and
approach the bank would have a
completely different interpretation
what's important and interesting about
this is that you're not really aware of
the interpretation that was rejected the
choice was made the choice is context
dependent and you're not aware of it oh
I have a story again a personal story to
tell about that particular mechanism
it's one of the best examples it
happened after I finished the book
otherwise I would have had to ask my
wife's permission to include it because
she's involved we were out to dinner
with friends and
and then you know we were talking about
about that evening and my wife said of a
man she said he is sexy all right
which and and then the next thing that
she said was truly bizarre and in fact
it was it was very very odd because she
said he doesn't underestimate himself
and I thought that's a very very
puzzling remark and I asked know what
what are you saying you know what's
what's going on it turned out but she
had actually said I'm a little hard of
hearing she had actually said he doesn't
underestimate himself
this this is a rich example because
because it never occurred to me and that
I think is something that you may
recognize in yourselves as well it never
occurred to me to think that if this
sentence was so bizarre probably I
misheard it that didn't look it to me I
knew what she had said you know the only
question was why did she say such a
thing and that is a very common
occurrence we take we accept you know
what we see and then we look for any
interpretation we do not question the
interpretation in many cases that turns
out to be a fundamental characteristic
of the way our mind works is the fact
that you know we hear the word and we
are not aware of alternative
interpretations this is true in
perception as well when we present and
big us stimuli an interpretation is
chosen it's chosen by the mechanism
we're not aware of the choice and we're
not aware of the rejected alternatives
so what is characteristic of the way
associative memory works is that it
produces an interpretation of the world
that is coherent and I want to elaborate
a bit on what that word coherence means
because there are really two very
different kinds of coherence there is a
logical coherence and logical coherence
has to do with operations of reasoning
so that you know if you believe that if
you believe that if a then B and if you
believe that a then you must believe
that be you know that's anything else
would be incoherent in that sense so
logic is a system of coherence this is
not the kind of coherence that
system one or fast-thinking or
associative memory the the relevant
concept for associative memory is fit
rather than logic it's things that go
together and as in the example I gave
you earlier maluma goes with a certain
kind of gesture and Tahiti goes with
another kind of gesture that's fit that
is coherence there's no logical
connection there is no you know there is
no logical necessity that relates it to
but in terms of fit it's very obvious
and it turns out that a lot of our
thinking and our emotional reactions are
governed by this kind of associative
coherence in ways that are really quite
difficult to control the psychologist
Paul Rosen is an expert in making people
psychologically uncomfortable and and
here is something that he does very
simple experiment so you take a bunch of
students and there's a glass of orange
juice in front of them and snicker that
they can write on and he asked them to
write the word cyanide in capital
letters and then to put the sticker on
the glass and then to drink the orange
juice and and they don't like it now I
mean it gets worse because he also has
the example of giving people a comb and
in its plastic wrapping and asking them
to stir milk with a comb perfectly clean
never been used in that plastic right
and and drink the milk absolutely not
now what happens here is there is a
connection and there is an associative
connection and it's associative it's
emotional in the the orange juice is
tainted by the label of cyanide and in a
way you just don't want to come near it
that's this is the way that system one
works now that's kind of emotional and
associative coherence is I think
extraordinarily important because it
explains our deepest beliefs you know
when when you look around you at what
people believe you know there are
religious positions there they really
just faithfully political positions
they're really very few of them and yet
and they think you know actually they
think that people on the other side are
sort of dumb low or ridiculous so how
could anyone believe in nonsense like
that that's the other people's belief
where does this come from
where does the certainty that we have in
our own beliefs come from why is it so
difficult to change people's minds on
issues of faith or political opinions I
mean you know you can debate things
until you're blue in the face and
basically very little happens except
people getting angry at other people's
stupidity
what seems to happen is related I think
to associative an emotional coherence
our beliefs
an association with people that we like
and love and trust that's what they
believe it's very difficult to find any
other reason or any other mechanism that
would explain why people grow into one
religion rather than another and grow
into a religion that they hold with
complete confidence because people know
what the truth is and that sense of
knowing but the truth is must come from
somewhere and it's rooted in a in an
emotional and associative history of
believing people trusting people people
telling you and you're finding yourself
believing in what they believe and say
there are other manifestations of
associative coherence one of them is
what psychologists call the halo effect
and it's it's easy to demonstrate by
mites opposite for example the idea that
Hitler adult faith love children and
dogs which is true by the way
and he was very kind to children and
dogs that is an unpleasant idea it
doesn't fit and we tend to our system
tends to create a coherent image of
people so the people that we like if
they have one good property the rest of
their properties tend to be good if we
dislike them we dislike the whole thing
you know people's attitudes say to
President Obama so if if you like his
politics very likely you like his voice
if you don't like his politics very
likely you think he is very big ears and
and you know he has a nice voice and he
doesn't big ears
but the the way that we perceive things
is associatively and emotionally
coherent and
that colors the way that we think about
many things and one of the almost
frightening examples of that I think is
what is called the affect heuristic
which is that people's attitude to
things is people's beliefs about things
are determined by whether they like them
or not and I can give you an example of
that um Paul slovic the psychologist who
is introduced this label of the effector
istic is interested in people's
attitudes to technologies and there are
technologies that people like and there
are technologies that they dislike and
you know so there are differences in
taste and and a very interesting thing
happens that when you collect people's
beliefs above the various technologies
if there is a technology that they don't
like then it has a lot of costs and
virtually no benefits so the correlation
between the number of costs that people
can think of in the number of benefits
that people can think of is sharply
negative in the real world that's very
unlikely to happen that way in general
choices are difficult because there is a
positive correlation between costs and
benefits but in people's mind that's not
the way it works
now you take new people with a
particular technology called you know it
could be fracking or it could be wind
turbines and and you provide people new
information about costs that they hadn't
thought of before so they now like the
technology less and interestingly enough
their ability to think of benefits of
the technology is impaired that is
you haven't said anything about benefits
all you've told them there are costs
that you didn't consider and now
benefits don't come to mind because we
tend to create an interpretation of the
world that is emotionally and
associatively coherent here is another
manifestation of the way the associative
system works and it's a question and the
question is is the following logical
argument valid that is does the
conclusion follow from the premises and
the argument is all roses or flowers
some flowers faint quickly therefore
some roses fade quickly in this valid
argument or not now the argument is not
valid because you know it could be that
the none of the flowers that fade
quickly is a rose so Rose don't there
are no roses let's read quickly but
about 80 percent I think above 80% of
students believe the state the statement
is logically valid the argument is
logically valid what happened well what
happened is the consequence is true for
people believe the consequence that
makes them believe the argument that
favors the consequence this is not the
way that thinking is supposed to work
thinking's supposed to work from
premises to conclusions but in fact what
happens is that if you believe in the
conclusion you tend to believe in the
arguments that go with the conclusion
this goes a fairly long way to
explaining political beliefs you believe
in the conclusions and you are inclined
to believe in any argument stronger weak
that is compatible with your beliefs by
the way it's a the same logical
structure it's trivially easy to see to
see it when it's presented
in terms of algebra then you see the
Venn diagrams very easily or if the
conclusion is false that you obviously
see that the argument is not valid so
there is a really important reason for
lesson from this that people reason
backwards and there is another
psychological reason that I want to
develop an EM coming close to the end of
the story and this is the following
notice would happen in that puzzle you
were asked so students are asked one
question which is is the argument valid
they apparently answer a different
question first and the different
question is is the conclusion true and
they infer validity from true and they
are not absolutely not aware that they
are doing this they answer a different
question from the question they were
asked this it turns out is a very
general mechanism now let me say
something in conclusion think about what
it means for a mind to generate
interpretations of a world that are
characterized by associative and
emotional coherence well that means that
the individual went this mine lives in a
world that is a lot simpler than the
real world because the real world
doesn't have that kind of coherence
Hitler did like dogs and little children
life is more complex than that it is
more complex than we're inclined to see
and we're not geared to perceive the
complexity now following on the other
line here of how did we answer the
question about the valid argument that
we answered a difficult question by
answering a simpler one this it turns
out is a very general mechanism system
one comes up with answer system one is
really stumped
it comes up with answers to questions
that it shouldn't be able to answer and
I call that substitution that you
substituted an easy question for the
hard one and it really happens a great
deal so let me give you an example one
of the most striking experimental
examples that I'm aware of this was
during the period of well in the 90s I
think that experiment was done there was
a fair amount of terrorism in Europe and
Americans were worried about traveling
to Europe because of terrorism an
experiment was done basically about
travel insurance and how much would be
people be willing to pay for travel
insurance and some people are asked to
put a price how much they would be
willing to pay for a policy that pays
$100,000 in case of death during your
trip for any reason other people were
asked how much would you pay for a
policy that pays $100,000 in case of
death in a terrorist incident during
this trip now the second policy is worth
a lot more than the first
now that really doesn't make sense
because if you you know dying in a
terrorist incident is not the only way
of dying in the trip in fact it's quite
unlikely so logically there is no
question about witches worth more but
that's not the way that people think
notice they are not asked to compare the
two policies if they were us to compare
the two policies many people would
figure it out that one of them is worth
is worth more than the other but when
they see one policy at a time so you
can't apply logic system two cannot be
applied to solve that problem to detect
a logical connection then we know what
people do they answer in terms of how
frightened they are how afraid they are
and people are more afraid of dying in a
terrorist incident than they're afraid
of the
and that actually and that makes perfect
sense I mean in terms of an association
you have more vivid images they're more
frightening and and if you decide on the
value of insurance by answering the
question how afraid am I at this event
then you will pay more for insurance
against terrorist incident than for
insurance against death many of the
examples know I did the research on
judgment my book is dedicated to my late
colleague Amos Tversky and we started
well more than 40 years ago now and we
dealt with mistakes that people make in
statistical judgments or failures to
apply statistical gentlemen and one of
the examples that we had was about a
fellow named Steve and we said he had
been sampled at random from the
population now and and we described
Steve as a meek and tidy soul with a
passion for detail relatively little
interest in people and then we asked the
steel more likely to be a farmer or a
librarian and the answer is immediate
most people immediately pick up that
Steve looks like a stereotypical
librarian I don't know the stereotype is
true
I doubt it but but that's what they
that's what people do and they think
that Steve is more likely to be a
librarian now in fact people also if
they stop to think about it would
realize that in the United States for
example there are about twenty times as
many male farmers as male librarians
there aren't many farmers and there are
many librarians many more male farmers
Steve is actually as I described it
there are more meek and tidy Souls on
farms they were than there are in
libraries that doesn't come to mind we
answer by comparing Steve to a
stereotype and Steve is more
like the stereotype of librarians then
Steve is like the stereotype of farmers
I will give you one more example just to
show you how thoughts that we generate
are dominated by associative thinking
and illustrate another characteristic of
associative thinking as I do this and
this is an example which I discuss in
the book in some detail actually it's
it's about the girl I call her Julie and
she is a graduating senior at the
University and I'm going to tell you one
fact about Julie and the fact is that
she read fluently when she was four
years old and I asked you to what is her
GPA and the interesting thing is you
know I can't see you because I'm blinded
but but all of you have a number you
have a GPA for Julie and as it happens
this is a rare case with psychologists
knows exactly what happened to you I can
tell you where that number came from
because this is a mechanism we
understand and this is how it worked
when I say Julie read fluently at age 4
you have an impression of how much that
says about how precocious a reader she
was you could you could do it in
percentiles you know whether she fit in
the distribution she is clearly not at
the absolute top but she is clearly way
above average in reading speed that
impression is immediate and that's the
way that we understand things we we have
immediate standards you know for many
traits when we're familiar with them
that enable us to perform the struggle
and automatically now how do we get the
GPA from there well it turns out we also
have a sense of the distribution of GPA
and what people do
is the GPA that came to your mind was
pretty close equally extreme as your
impression of our precocious reader
Julie was you matched and this ability
to match things across dimensions you
know if you could ask in in New York or
in another city how tall were the
building how many stories would a
building would have to have to be as
tall as Judi was precocious in her
reading and you can do that too
yet we can match we can match across
intensity dimensions naturally were very
good at that
this is this is part of the machinery of
the associative machinery and it gets
used in answering questions that were
not asked so in fact what happened is
when that GPA came to your mind you were
not answering the right question you
were answering the wrong question how
precocious was a reading and you were
matching across dimensions to a GPA that
is as Extreme as your impression was by
the way statistically this is completely
wrong this is absolutely wrong it's a
serious mistake
it's about as serious and it's about the
same kind of mistake as neglecting what
we call the base rate in the case of
Steve the librarian but that's the
mechanism so in a whole set of
situations we ask ourselves questions
and we come up with the answer to a
simple question
it comes up automatically through an
associative process it is not random we
don't answer any old question there must
be a connection between the two
precociousness intelligence GPA they
belong to the same context and we match
we shouldn't it's statistically wrong
but this is the way we do it let me
conclude
the mind that I've described and are
really focused on system 1 and sort of
assumed that in many cases of the system
2 endorses the suggestion of system 1 if
you notice and all the examples in the
last 10 minutes that were the case we
asked a question that sounds like a slow
thinking type of question but people's
answers are really dominated by
something that happened in their
associative memory the basic analogy is
there it's the visual system that is the
way I think about it with guides my
thinking about fast thinking is that a
lot of the many of the rules that apply
to visual perception extend in a fairly
natural way to the domain of intuitive
thinking to how we think associatively
and intuitively that's I'm anticipating
something that is my one of my reasons I
mean I'm pessimist you know I'm a
pessimist my temperament I introduced
myself as a pessimist but one of the
reasons I think that it's difficult to
change the mind the way the mind works
is that you have to imagine changing the
way that our visual system works and
that is certainly very very difficult
and I think that changing the way the
mind works may not be a lot easier so
that's that's a story I wanted to tell
you I'm just wondering I want to give
you an example of how that can be
applied because you know this I think
that this kind of analysis lends itself
to many applications and I'll give you
I'll spend a few minutes
answering a question I haven't been
asked yet which is how does the two
system mind know things what does it
mean for a to system mind to know things
and I actually anticipated the answer
earlier to know something you know in
the language that there's a proper
definition of knowledge somebody said to
know that X if X is true and the person
believes that X is true with high
confidence
that's called knowing that's a
definition of knowing the psychological
state of knowing is different
psychological state of knowing is when
no alternative comes to mind it is when
you have a single alternative that fits
that is coherent with the context and it
fits with everything else and no
alternative then we feel we know
whatever it is that we are thinking at
the time in the same way that I thought
I knew what my wife had said when in
fact I didn't know it but subjectively
no alternative came to mind that's what
she had said in fact an alternative
existed and the key here is not tricking
it's not being aware that an alternative
might exist and that is the case in the
perceptual system and it turns out to be
the case in intuitive thinking as well
so that I think is what explains or
contributes to the explanation of why
people think they know that their
religious faith is correct or their
political position is correct or their
beliefs about other things and they
really have no evidence for and their
their beliefs are correct it's because
the intuitive system the
societal system doesn't deliver an
alternative and in order to modify that
system so we had a conversation with
Stuart just before I before the lecture
we should have it earlier I would have
prepared differently but it's clear that
Stuart and Danny Hillis with with whom
we were talking earlier they they
believe that the mind can change they
believe the mind will change and that if
the mind itself will not change it can
be so it can be augmented by by
instruments that will help us think
better and that's the way that one would
think we know of examples where this
kind of augmentation clearly works we
know for example that pilots can be
trained to fly by instruments that's a
very different kind of flying than
flying by the seat of their pants
all right flying by visual perception is
it possible to imagine augmenting
people's cognition by the equivalent of
flying by instruments fascinating
question I don't have an answer I mean
you know my my inclination is to be
pessimistic but but i but in this case I
think I'm wrong I think there will be
ways in which we can improve thinking
well augmenting it by possibly by
suggesting alternatives so you could
imagine in some situations that there is
a device that whispers in your ears that
your interpretation is not the only one
now if we would be terribly
uncomfortable with such a device then
you know but there are occasions when
you're making when you're in an
important situation when it's very
important not to make mistakes when
mistakes are costly that's when somehow
you would
consistent do to be more active and
that's where somehow we would need the
equivalent of flying by instruments or
at least instrument that would guide us
in how to fly and how to think we're a
long way from getting there thank you
[Applause]
I'll explain that that's weird
got your attention in a different way
there didn't we so much of your research
seems like it's been done in
collaboration obviously with Amos
Tversky and with Richard thaller and
others that you mentioned in your work
say something about collaboration versus
old research well I have mostly you know
most of my work has been collaborative
well I'd like to talk with people it
comes back for me to me and I like doing
this in in my collaboration with Amos
Tversky which is you know the basis for
the book really not that he would have
liked the book in its I'm not sure he
would but why what do you know well
because we had that that was what I was
about to say with that we were different
so we were different and yet similar
enough to understand each other but
different enough to surprise each other
and to present you know different points
of view and we liked each other so much
and we were so practiced at working
together that we were enriched by those
differences so we had different tastes
but when there was something that both
of us liked it was bound to be pretty
good so there was - there were those two
filters kind of a Venn diagram
approached you for there's overlap here
you're really onto something
did that work I remember at one point
you collaborated with a real sort of
opponent in the whole psychological
world know that I hate controversies you
know that's there's a lot of emotion in
science I mean it's not
they're people who enjoy controversy
that people hate it and I belong to the
latter group and I hate being angry
actually that's that's really what
happens you roar when you get angry one
occasion yeah but on that occasion there
was somebody is someone it was become a
friend whose position on issues of
intuitive thinking is really about the
hundred and eighty degrees of mind that
is he his life project is to show that
expert intuition is wonderful and you
know I don't know how you'd characterize
my life project but it certainly is not
in that direction I mean I've been I've
done more work on flaws of intuitive
thinking then on the marvels of
intuitive thinking but we collaborated
in trying you know we both agreed
intuitive thinking sometimes flawed and
sometimes marvelous and we collaborated
in trying to find the boundary and I
think we did a truly I mean you know it
wasn't revolutionary other people had
had come to approximately the same
conclusions but we did that
collaboratively over a period of years
that was not the same thing as you know
as much fun as it was with Amos Tversky
but but it was profoundly satisfying
because we did we did manage to a green
in fact the title wallpaper was I forget
with the first part of the file is but
the second part is a failure to disagree
we there's a question that came in from
a live stream from Molly know what does
humor do to change or teach system one
or his humor related to system two
surprises interruption or stereotypes
all of that and there's some lot of
study on what makes a joke a joke
I mean clearly there isn't you know I'm
not an expert on that but there is
clearly an element of surprise in humor
that that is part of it
humor is profoundly important to the
workings of system one
pleasure is fundamentally important to
the working system one it turns out we
think they're friendly when we're in a
good mood or when we're in a bad mood
when we're in a bad mood system two
tends to be more active we're more
vigilant we check ourselves more when
we're in a good mood we're more
intuitive we tend to be more creative
so there's many associations between
humor pleasure and the workings of
intuitive system so the way to trick
people in system two is to make some
jokes that get them into it that's that
I think by the way is one way when you
want people to loosen up and come up
with ideas you could do worse than
telling you Joe sahel yes have you found
any evidence that long-term use of
stimulants such as Ritalin
I hadn't all coffee we talked about
beforehand or SSRIs effects or changes
that balance between people's operating
system water system - I don't know it's
I just don't know the answer to that
question okay and be fun to do the
research yep
with some of the substances we were
saying to each other before Hanna's we
were clutching her a cup of coffee that
there's clearly something going on with
the caffeine and you spoke kindly of
nicotine I think that should be said
right out loud yeah I mean I used to be
a heavy smoker and I I don't think you
know I I honestly think I was smarter
when I was a smoke smoking but a whole
people a lot of people's association
just got jolted this is like this is
like Hitler loving children and being a
vegetarian Carter asks big wicked
problems like climate change requires to
understand the world and new and complex
ways are we doomed because of the
difficulty of overcoming our initial
associative thinking now that's supposed
to left of my heart if I think this
analysis is really frightening when its
implications for the reaction to climate
change because my sense is that
mobilizing people to action and in
particular to cost the action involves
emotion it involves system one you've
got to speak to system one to mobilize
people to act in significant way and the
problem is whether you can arouse
emotions and global warming as as a very
you know frightening characteristic
which is that by the time it's obvious
that we're in trouble it may be too late
to avert the trouble this is the kind of
threat for which system one is really
very poorly prepared so that I think
there's then the sense of that question
and I know there is a book david
Runciman an important Englishman English
scholar is is coming out with a book
whether democracy can handle problems
such as climate change and he raised us
exactly I've been framing it can
democracies handle climate change that's
a century size problem of global size
problem yeah
and it's it it looks as if full dealing
with climate change with authoritarian
systems of traveler [ __ ] system might
actually be better better able to
recognize the distant threat and take
action what we have in the United States
it's really quite remarkable what is
happening with respect to beliefs in
nobody can really make a judgement about
global change you know except the
experts and the experts most of them
almost all of them agree but where do I
believe in the reality of global change
its global climate really it's it's
exactly an example of what I was talking
to earlier I believe in the people who
believe in climate change so you see
other scientists say is probably right
yeah and and you know there are other
people who say that if somebody you know
like a preacher they believe in says not
to worry about that there are other
worries then not to worry
then there is another problem that
arouses too that arises here which is
we're trying to believe that if there
are two opinions then you know who knows
nobody can tell that very insidious
that's you know there are there are two
opinions there are people who are saying
the other thing scientists may know
that's you know there is a huge
difference in both in number and in
reputation between those who favor one
position and those who favor another the
public doesn't very difficult
four people asked what happened after
you ward
I forgot to tell you they were very
puzzled and and they stopped in their
tracks and they walked back to their car
that's a successful ELISA revoir CEO has
a question that always comes up how do
you think our brains increasing
codependence that the Internet is
impacting the uses of system 1 and
system 2 if any
what is you know what you see is all
there is is both exacerbated in a way on
the internet where you can see the
beautiful thing the same thing but it's
also there's a lot more leakage it's
that's right I mean I don't think that
this is a simple answer we are we're you
know in a world where we we do have
developed the habit of looking things up
you know looking things up exposes you
to two sources and I I think that's you
know this is a profound change that have
occurred I don't know how to describe it
in terms of system 1 and system 2
but looking things up as as a way to
resolve differences as a way to figure
out what is really going on and then
there are trusted sources then there is
you know Wikipedia as only there is
something we all trust and you look
things up that's that's important you
know that's going to have an impact on
[Music]
hope what's going on with our physiology
right now this event was cut a little
short by a fire alarm in the building
[Music]
[Music]